let's go next to where do we want to go
next i don't know
um how about nico
from santa monica you're on the air
hi david how's it going it's going well
so i had a i had a question about
um i have a question about running
democrats
who are socially conservative
but fiscally liberal okay um
i know a lot of times you say like if
you run a bernie sanders
in joe manson joe manchin's west
virginia
right you just get a republican right
but
do you think that um do you think that
you can run somebody who is
kind of in line with bernie on maybe
certain
fiscal issues who's um
who's not necessarily in line with him
on gun rights or abortion rights or
something like that
yeah i think that if if there is a
situation
in which abortion rights aren't really
at risk
and you know if if democrats control the
house
and it's sort of like there's not really
you know whatever is happening at the
state level could happen at the state
level but federally there's really no
risk for example to abortion rights
i don't really have a problem having uh
a democrat in the senate for example
whose personal views are
that they're against abortion he or she
is against abortion
and has some conservative social
positions
if on economics they're going to be a
strong vote
for everything you know from
infrastructure spending to a more
equitable tax system
etc that that's a trade i would make in
other words
as opposed to a republican if we have to
accept that there's parts of the country
where the type of democrat that can win
is one that is economically progressive
and socially conservative i would accept
that
as long as there's no real chance of
their socially conservative views
becoming law and that would depend on
who controls the senate who controls the
house at the time but that's
i don't i don't like it those aren't my
views but i think that there would be
much to gain from having a reliable vote
on the economic issues that i would say
ah whatever they're against abortion but
abortion's just not an issue right now
abortion rights aren't in question and
we'll just kind of ignore that and hope
we get some good economic policy
do you think that that could be a
blueprint uh for democrats
um maybe not not not to a not to an
enormous scale because
it could compromise some of our um
social values but do you think that
could be a blueprint for democrats
taking back some
uh more socially conservative areas that
they used to that they used to
win or not necessarily win but yeah like
kentucky or missouri
as a strategy to take republican seats
if that's the only way to do it i'm okay
with it yeah
fair enough thanks david all right nico
from santa monica
thank you very much for the call